لو تحدثنا عن الهجوم المضاد ما هو
السيناريو الاكثر تفضيلا جندي ضد جندي
دبابه مقابل دبابه
سؤالك يثير نقاشا لانه فيما يتعلق بالسلاح
او بالدول اعضاء الناتو التي تزود
اوكرانيا بالعتاد فان الجنرالات يرغبون
بصفه عامه برؤيه قتال يرغبون في استخدام
التجهيزات التي جرى انفاق الكثير عليها من
اجل نقلها الى اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده
ام فقط ملا يقل عن 900 مليار دولار في
موازنه دفاعيه هذا اكثر من عشره اضعاف
اجمالي مساهمت به كل الدول الاعضاء الاخرى
في الناتو مجتمعه هذا مبلغ ضخم وخيالي لدى
اوكرانيا هذا الكم من الصواريخ والدبابات
والتجهيزات وكل المساهمين يرغبون برؤيتها
وهي بصدد الاستخدام هم يرغبون بان يثبتوا
لدافع الضراء بان تمويل هذه التجهيزات كان
مبررا وكان استثمارا من اجل القومي ايضا
هناك منافسه تجاريه امريكا مصدر كبير
للسلاح وكذلك روسيا فنحن بصدد حرب
بالوكاله وكبار مسلحيها سلاح او مصنعيه هي
يرغبون بهذا القتال بين افضل ما انتجت
التكنولوجيا العسكريه الغربيه
ومنافستها الروسيه ولذلك وردا على سؤالك
حول ماهيه المعركه المرتقبه فان من يقف
وراء التسليح يرغب برؤيه معركه تقوم على
الاقتراب والمواجهه المباشره نوعا ما قوات
تواجه قوات سلاح بسلاح دبابه بدبابه طائره
بطائره صاروخ بصاروخ او جندي بجندي باننا
الان لدينا مسيرات وغيرها من التحديثات ما
يوفر فرصه لعرض هذه الانجازات لكن هناك
تحدي امام اوكرانيا والدول التي تسلحها
فهي لا ترغب برؤيه تغطيه مباشره للمعركه
على هواء الشاشات
القنوات التلفزيونيه حتى لا تكون هناك
فرصه لمشاهده التدمير اختراعاتهم بقوه
السلاح الروسي